[Music]
in ursula k le green's third earth sea
novel the farthest shore we get to learn
quite a bit more about dragons and
encounter many more of them in the
narrative than we have in a wizard of
earth see
and in the rule of names it's actually
the same dragon
in both of those right and one of the
most important ones in this story is
called worm embar there's also another
earlier dragon named orm who is orm m
barr's kinsmen
and that is this legendary dragon who
fought aerith ekba the
great culture hero of earth see both of
them killing each other in the process
and orms the original orms uh bones are
actually part of a structure that's
going to show up a little bit later orm
embar is very much alive
and he in fact is the first dragon who
we're going to encounter
in this narrative about
two-thirds of the way through he seeks
ged out there's a back story there that
we'll go into shortly but he seeks get
out on the open sea
landing on one of the rafts and here's
the
the account that takes place
the mage looked up startled his face
became fierce and exalting and he
shouted aloud in the old speech of the
making nam hetwa
which in the speech of the making is if
thou seeketh ged here find him
and like a golden plummet dropped with
wings held high outstretched vast and
thundering on the air with talons that
might see season ox as if it were a
mouse with a curl of steamy flame
streaming from long nostrils the dragon
stooped like a falcon onto the rocking
raft and there's a little bit further
description the dragon hovered above
them 90 feet maybe he
was from tip to tip of his vast
membranous wings that's shown in the new
sunlight like gold shot smoke and the
length of his body was no less but lean
arched like a greyhound clawed like a
lizard and snakes scaled along the
narrow spine went a row of jagged darts
like rose thorns in shape but at the
hump of the back three feet in height
so diminishing that the last at the tail
tip was no longer than the blade of a
little knife these thorns were gray and
the scales of the dragon were iron gray
but there was a glitter of gold in them
his eyes were green
and slitted and interestingly enough the
chief of these people
you know seeing this massive dragon says
well i better do something about this
comes out with a with a harpoon and
aaron tackles him and says stay out of
this one just let god handle it
so
why is the dragon there he he is seeking
get out specifically aryan or lebanon is
going to be coming along for the ride
and there is a mission in mind one that
ties in with their larger
quest
so the dragon speaks with
ged in the old speech the voice was soft
and hissing almost like a cat when he
cries out softly in rage
but huge and there was a terrible music
in it
they speak and then the mage answers one
word memeos i will come and he lifted up
his staff of you wood the dragon's jaws
opened a coil of smoke escaped the gold
wings clapped like thunder
making a great wing that smelled of
burning and he wheeled and flew hugely
to the north and at this point what are
they going to do god says now we have to
go say your farewells and and come and
they get into look far
uh ged's boat and now they're gonna pull
out the stops of magic in the past ged
was content to let the winds more or
less take them where they were going to
go
now he is going to use all that's at
disposal of of the the wind key and
follow
all the way to
celador
a thousand miles it's mentioned what is
the backstory here that we have
ged tells us
that was worm embar
the dragon of cellador kin to the great
orm who slew akba and was slain by him
and aaron says was he hunting lord
hunting me
when dragons hunt they find he came to
ask my help and then ged says and that
is the thing i would not believe if
anyone told me that a dragon turned to a
man for help and of them all that one he
is not the oldest though he is very old
but he is the mightiest of his kind
he does not hide his name as dragons and
men must do he has no fear
that any can gain power over him nor
does he deceive
in the way of his kind long ago on
cellador he let me live and he told me a
great truth
he told me how the rune of the kings
might be refound to him i owe the ring
of ereth akba
never did i think to repay such a debt
to such a creditor so
the ring of areth akbar
was the one that was restored in the
previous novel the tombs of ottawa
and it's going to play a major role as
well in the novels yet to come so this
is a pretty important
thing and notice what he says about this
dragon he does not lie or deceive the
way that other dragons do he doesn't
hide his name because he has no fear
of anyone so this this makes him rather
unusual
ged goes on a little bit and he says
he's going to show me the way i seek he
said in the west there's another dragon
lord
who works destruction on us and his
power is greater than ours i said even
then thine ormbar and he said even than
mine i need thee follow in haste and so
that is exactly what they do
uh ged and aaron who at this point you
know we may as well just call him
lebanon by his true name because that's
what the dragon calls him they follow
and they go all the way to celador
ormbar
his speech
he's going to be communicating with ged
and lebanon through a number of the the
incidents here so he's informing ged
about what's happening there's more to
it and as ged says dragons it's science
it's kind of tough to figure out what
they're
saying sometimes the meaning precisely
you know is the bad guy on cellador the
you know orem says yes and no
so then you have to figure out what that
means but he's able to understand from
this story
that the other dragons the ones that
they encounter in the dragons run
have had something absolutely central
and vital essential to them taken away
their capacity to use the old or true
speech the language of the making
dragons don't learn language they
already have
and you might say
swim in language
and to have that taken away from them
makes them
like animals which they they aren't just
brutes the way that other animals are
they're like human beings except you
know being dragon kind of course
and so he's informing gad about what's
taking place that
all of these uh other dragons have
encountered whatever this enemy is this
dragon lord and he
you know they they kill him and he keeps
coming back they become afraid of him
and through their fear
this allows him to
take away from them
their speech which places them in this
this very bad situation
so
orm embars is speaking with the two of
them
and there's a couple interesting
exchanges i particularly like where he's
talking
um with lebanon because that in effect
transforms him into
a
dragon lord doesn't it um
here we go let me let me find this so
there's a couple places where they wind
up together
here
iron saw what might have been an eagle
flying very high but it was not an eagle
it circled and stooped
down it came with that thunder and
shrill whistle of outspread golden wings
the dragon crawled a little way down the
slope and spoke agni labon
standing between it and get iron ass
answered orm embar and he held his bare
sword in his hand it did not feel heavy
now and the dragon spoke again aaron
could not understand he said to the
dragon my lord is weary he sleeps and
then notice what happens after this
at that arm embar crawled and coiled on
down to the bottom of the dell he was
heavy on the ground not least and free
as when he flew but there was a sinister
grace in the slow pacing of his great
talent feet and the curving of his
thorny tail once there he drew his legs
beneath him lifted up his huge head and
was still like a drab like a dragon
carved on a warrior's helm
aaron was aware of his yellow eye
not ten feet away and the faint reek of
burning that hung about him this was no
carrion stink
dry and metallic and accorded with the
faint odors of the sea and the salt sand
a clean
wild smell
again ged sleeps on and
aaron finally falls asleep
waking up finds the mage and set up
beside him and gad says to him have you
gotten so used to dragons you fall
asleep between their boss
so you know this is this is something
very unusual you know aaron or lebanon
has gotten to experience something that
very very few people do
and he's participating in this dragon
lordship of of ged himself
now what ends up happening shortly after
that
is
oram embar is
robbed of his own
speech and
this is a significant
problem ged says he cannot speak he
cannot speak the words of the making are
taken from him he is left like an adder
like a tongueless warm worm his wisdom
dumb yet he can lead and we can follow
so they go eight miles following orm
embar he crouches on the ivory sand his
head low-like and angry cats and his
breath coming in gasps of fire
some way
before him between him and the long
breakers of the sea stood a thing like a
hut or shelter white as if built of long
bleached driftwood but there was no
driftwood on this shore which faced no
other land
aaron saw the ramshackle walls were
built up of great bones whale bones that
he thought at first and then saw the
white triangles edged like knives and
knew they were the bones of a dragon
and here they meet their enemy
ged summons him he doesn't have his name
so he just includes the enemy in the
summoning and then the guy shows up and
says oh you can't summon me i come of my
own accord i am no shadow i'm only alive
uh and then he says do you know what
this is that i've got he's got this this
long rod or blade of steel graven all
down its length with runes and he says
this is the staff of the gray mage and
he reaches out with the steel blade to
touch ged who stood as if he could not
move and could not speak aryan stood a
pace between him and all his will was to
move but he could not stir he could not
even put his hand on his sword hilt and
his voice was stopped in his throat and
here is where orm embar acts
over get an aaron over their heads vast
and fiery the great body of the dragon
came in one writhing leap and plunged
down full force on the other so that the
charmed steel blade entered into the
dragon's male breast to its full length
but the man was born down under his
weight and crushed
and burnt
this kills orm embar he vomits out gouts
of fire and screams he tries to fly but
cannot malign and cold the metal lay in
his heart he crouched and the blood ran
black and poisonous steaming from his
mouth and the fire died in his nostrils
till they became like pits of ash he
laid his great head down on the sand so
died orm embar where his forefather orm
died on the bones of orm buried in the
sand and now it seems like all has
really been been lost the dragon has
been
killed he never recovers his voice he
sacrifices himself
in some respect is he doing this just to
attack the evil one is he trying to save
ged and iron what we don't know
what we do know of the effect however
is that where ormond struck his enemy to
the earth there laid something ugly and
shriveled like the body of a big spider
dried up in its web it had been burned
by the dragon's breath and crushed by
his talon's feet as aaron watched it
moved it crawled a little away from the
dragon
the face lifted up towards them there
was no comeliness left in it only ruined
old age that it outlived old age
so get an arron so at last the living
face of their enemy it turned away
the burnt blackened arms reached out and
a darkness gathered into them the same
shapeless darkness that swelled and
dimmed the sunlight between the arms of
the unmaker
it was like an archway or a gate
though dim and without outline and
though it was neither pale sand or ocean
through it was neither pale sand nor
ocean but a long slope of darkness going
down into the dark
this is where the figure crawls into the
broken body of the enemy
and ged says to lebanon
let's enter and that is how they
enter the dry land the land of the dead
where they will now face the enemy orm
embar through his sacrifice
has
unwittingly produced this possibility
of tackling the one who has been
injuring
and perhaps even destroying
his kind
you